We're operating LGBTQIA rights
into Columbia's curriculum
is not just a good idea.
It's essential.
Because LGBTQIA people
around the world are often used as the
canary in the coal mine.
Let's test out how strong
the arm of oppression can
be.
Let's see how far we can push
people into the shadows through
mass arrests.
The deregistering of LGBTQIA
organizations.
The raids.
On Pride events and community
gatherings and also
you know torture
and killing so the LGBTQOIA people
especially human rights defenders
so caring about LGBTQIA
issues is not just a matter
of placating LGBTQI
students or doing something that feels
good.
It is a matter of understanding
how governments have shifted
their discourse.
Towards populist ethno
nationalism and who
is most impacted by those
policies.
And so if we don't look at how out
LGBTIQ people are being treated
if we don't look at the shift in law and
public policy and if we don't look
at community based solutions.
Then we not only risk seeing more
violence against LGBTIQ
people but we risk misunderstanding
the growing targeting of minorities
and the attacks on democracy.